we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
eric from mass has been calling in for
the entire pandemic
saying we're about to blow the lid off
of this thing
and he again says it it's about to
happen we're about to get the truth on
the pandemic and when we do i'm going to
be screwed take a look at this
hey david it's er from mass the cdc is
about to come out with the real numbers
of the pandemic right it's going to be
cutting a fourth
uh they're going to admit the pcie tests
don't work so that's going to be half of
that so none of that's true the pcr
tests work there's there's actually more
cases than the number that we are seeing
um coveted numbers are not overblown
we've debunked this endless times 400
000
and then half of them would have flew so
it'll be about 200 000 which proves
whoever in a pandemic to begin with the
pci tests were wrong and of course all
of this is lies but eric really thinks
any day any day it's going to come out
took a vaccine for nothing um
but what will you do
you will
lie and evade and make blame everyone
else it's gonna be the funniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen i can't wait well show me
the numbers my friend because uh every
one of this guy's predictions over the
last two years
have been utterly wrong
we've got a great bonus show for you
today joe biden calls for a change to
the filibuster in a major voting rights
speech we will talk about it
extreme weather in the u.s is believed
to have cost 688 lives last year how how
do you even calculate something like
that we will discuss and the justice
department is creating a unit focused on
domestic terrorism
what will they do
who is in favor of it who is against it
you can probably guess the answers to
some of those questions get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at joinpakman.com
we are still banned from facebook
monetization
you can use the coupon code f facebook
that's facebook with two fs
to get a discounted membership to help
us make up that revenue loss f facebook
is the coupon code and we will see you
on the bonus show